ahoy captain what are you doing there
are I'm trying to build a docker image
for this old job application that I have
it's a great application that keeps
track of all my fishing routes let me
tell you about those by the way
trim your sails captain why don't you
juice jib for that jib jib I know all
about sales genuis Spinnaker's top sales
hang on Captain jib is a tool that
builds containers for your java
applications without needing much
knowledge of docker best practices
shiver me timbers tell me more about
this newfangled trickery
take me to your helm captain you mean my
terminal
yeah yeah right let's start with the
basic Oh world java application oh you
mean a hello world application yeah
let's go and grab a sample application
from the web oh I know just the one so
Jeb works great with both Gradle and
maven I'll show you how to do it with
Gradle today okay Cap'n oh you run a
tight ship sailor let's do that first
let's take a look at the jib page online
the grail QuickStart shows you how to
get started
super easy just add the plug-in to build
up Gradle file no but where should I put
that code put it directly after that
build script entry that's all you need
well that's smooth sailing sailor now
let's build that just type Gradle Jib
now our pirates that did not work sailor
I forgot to say not only does she build
the container image it's also sends it
to a container registry of your choice
oh I keep all my containers on the ship
sailor I mean Google Cloud container
registry ok that's good now just add the
image argument to the same command oh
that was easy
that's all there is to it shipshape and
Bristol fashion sailor let's try it out
locally with docker oh I know this one
now let's shake it's in shipshape I'm
gonna go to the localhost and check that
the app is running through docker so now
that you have your container image you
can run it anywhere you can run
containers like kubernetes Q&A is did
you know that Cuban ADEs means helmsman
in Greek now that's another funny
nautical reference we put in this script
mm-hmm thanks captain anyway that's how
easy jib makes it to container eyes to
job application no dr. mastery needed
are now don't forget subscribe for more
great Google cloud platform content
[Music]